hello and welcome to this video playing
silencer Baba okay
you're not going to silence me Baba if
he plays at all he does
they have such a scary name and then
they play these openings playing playing
alpha zero style who in the a6 okay
there should be three
[Music]
well the Italian game is very well was
opening says she's just so he just sucks
the life out of you
no I'm not worthy or anything but really
tough to get anything going
you okay he's doing something hooray not
unhappy I can do stuff
give me the sender okay it's not like
I'm having having the center of it at
least some things happen
my idea was to play a form I probably
will go Knight f5 and I probably need
some protection there I'm not
threatening f5 because he can still take
on f5 and I know he cannot of course
so I'm threatening at five well I mean I
can play it I'm not sure it's a threat
but I'm able to play this move
that was the idea okay now if I take
eggs I can I can also do this I mean
it's not necessary to immediately take
okay so b5 he's going to go to be to I
guess okay why is he taking with the
rook just just with the rook he took
with the rook
it's not a big deal I can go to e4 and
he will take with the rock yeah I
thought Queenie form
[Music]
I can I can take the free right t3
look these three rook takes e4 d1
checking of to check on a form but
uncertain about this should be good yeah
okay what the heck was that
getting some wacky messages here sorry
for the system messages not Skype or
anything so um where is he going there
his queen is very short on squeeze
[Music]
I think it probably best is b5 pushing
the night back to be to first that is
probably right
after night b2 if I just play rook to b1
how does he save this night I guess he
doesn't
oh that's funky
[Music]
and now how do we play this this is for
sure good for me as I can just take a
good look f7
yeah I have nine seconds this is the
problem the position is fairly easy to
win
he's got a terrible night down age form
this is an this is an issue him I can
let's let's do this first
go back
just want some improved coordination my
night should improve somehow to as to to
some square where is covered
it was not very intelligent to allow a
form
I wanted I'm playing for for the attack
now with G form
gee formate is that is the idea
where's the maid I don't see the maid
checkmate
whoo Wow Wow I will shine tens at the
end so um okay let's let's let's have a
look down cause so a tough game so I was
quite happy here
I mean I'm nicely centralized it should
be an okay position
g6s five and I'm a little bit better
here right yeah so that was the
devaluation was not totally off now rook
g1 look at the eight-three and now the
engine just wanted wants to improve the
position with the move like King to g7
okay yeah I wanted to get something
immediately and took rook takes Queen
e-form but it seems that after look ft2
I'm okay but it's not a huge thing 0.6
okay but this is good right d3 is
winning up there that wins so this is a
winning position I just need to give a
more precise I'm going to going to win
directly so b5 is one of the winners
here would be 524 to KITT so I didn't I
didn't do do too badly him it's it's
winning the whole time
Knight f5 it's not so precise but okay
this is like I had no time
[Music]
and I was playing for made and I think I
think it should should win the a porn is
so far away now I had had the made
already with this okay this is uh oh no
okay hy I had no time but yeah here we
got a made as well
Wow tough but I didn't play too badly
I'm quite quite happy with what I did I
mean there was some some imprecisions
but nothing nothing terrible okay guys
thanks for watching